[Music]
how much has changed since march the
24th qb one
andy dalton qb one they have a new qb
who wears number one in justin fields
here's andy dalton talking about his
mindset after he learned
that the bears had traded up nine spots
in the first round to select the ohio
state quarterback
i knew the situation i was going into
regardless of the draft of somebody or
they didn't i was on a one-year deal and
i was going to be the starter so my
mindset didn't have to change i already
knew that i'm going to do everything i
can to be the best player i can for this
team and to help us win a lot of
football games and that's been my goal
from the very beginning and so whatever
happens after this year happens but
my mindset didn't change just because
they drafted justin
yeah look what else is he going to say
what else is he going to say yeah and
he'll get a chance he'll get a chance
presumably mike glennon got four games
in 2017 before they went with mitchell
trubisky and if andy dalton comes out
and plays well
maybe they do decide to keep justin
fields on the bench and i keep coming
back to that nagging sense i have matt
neggie's experience 2017 with the chiefs
yeah put patrick mahomes on ice for the
whole year different from the standpoint
of andy dalton's equity with the bears
none and alex smith's with the chiefs
right plenty but but nagi saw that work
and
only he knows what went on well others
with the chiefs do but he's the only one
with the bears who knows what went on
behind the curtain to get patrick
mahomes ready he may have a plan a
hundred point plan here's how you get
your first round quarterback ready so he
can come out and set the league on fire
in his second season chris yeah no i i
don't disagree with your thought i i
would certainly think that you know that
thought's percolating in his brain and
everybody in the the bears organization
but i also think like um
it is a different situation like you
explained you know the chiefs were good
a play-off team
alex smith was kind of looked at like a
franchise-ish
type quarterback still
where
we know what andy dalton is i think we
know what the bears fans think he is i
mean they weren't like you know storming
the streets and like yes we got andy
dalton qb one here we go super bowl no
so there's gonna be tremendous
i can already tell just by a few of the
you know media obligations i've done in
chicago there's gonna be tremendous
pressure
on justin fields it's our or on the
bears organization to get justin fields
on the field i just think there's a
clamoring for that already there is so
uh there there
this is a different type of scenario and
i think they're going to be i think
ultimately a little bit more anxious to
put fields out there and see what he can
do as compared to that mahomes and
kansas city chief situation
sometimes the answer is hiding in plain
sight yeah when andy dalton says i knew
the situation i was going into
regardless of if they drafted somebody
or they didn't i was on a one-year deal
and i was going to be
the starter
if a promise was made to andy dalton to
get him to sign and that promise is not
honored that that's a bigger issue for
the bears not that promises
are broken all the time in pro sports
yeah but
if matt nagy
and or ryan pace gave their word to andy
dalton that he's the starter
and it meant something more than your qb
one for march april may june and that
part of july when we don't have training
camp then after that all bets are off
you got to sing for your supper you got
to earn your spot
if a promise was made that he's the
starter to start the season
yeah then he is he is sunday night
football right andy dalton and the bears
take on matthew stafford and the rams
period yeah so and now by week two that
doesn't mean right we started your week
one yeah exactly right he's the starter
if they they that that confidence from
dalton who's been around for a decade
speaks to me that a promise was made to
him will the promise be honored that's
really the question if that promise was
made and and when we look at his words
that implies to me that they told him
you're the starter week one yeah i i i
feel the same way mike i don't think i
was like hey we promise you you're going
to be the starter i that that is like
a rare thing to hear from any coach on
anything but not wired a wire but yeah
but i think they probably said hey we're
going to you here and you're going to be
our starting quarterback and let's see
where it goes now i mean he was aware of
the situation as he explained and
everything like that so you know that's
yeah i would bet there was something
like that said by the way that andy
dalton what is this the second or third
or fourth time we've kind of heard him
say this publicly
but that also doesn't mean yeah you
could start and hey like i talked about
yesterday or with justin fields third
series of the first game hey we got a
justin fields package we're gonna get it
going we're gonna see what we got here
and see if we can't you know create
create some schematical advantages for
our football team because this guy has a
different skill set all together you
know i i feel like
in a lot of ways
this might be the like
out of the quarterbacks drafted in the
first round they're just the most
pressure on the quarterback situation
because the bears fans and the are so
thirsty for a franchise quarterback it's
justin fields they've seen what he's
done in college football and all those
type of things it's andy dalton and man
if he has any success in these preseason
games i just think the whole fan base
and the whole city is going to be like
what are we waiting for let's just go
let's play him he looks great so what if
he's not perfect and that's where i
think it could be a lot of pressure on
this situation
this is a team
that hasn't had
a franchise quarterback
since sid luckman jay cutler was the
closest that they came he hit he had a
lot of stats set a lot of team records
but didn't have a lot of success in the
whole get to the playoffs and win games
they got to the nfc championship in 2010
lost to the packers remember that
controversy where is cutler really
injured yeah right play should he have
played but they're clamoring for a
franchise quarterback they're still
reeling from trading up to take mitchell
trubisky instead of standing pat to take
patrick mahomes they can't get past that
and they traded up
to get see the guy who was one of the
most polarizing pre-draft figures with
the opinions about whether or not he's
gonna make it all the ingredients are
there right for there to be a ton of
pressure right and a ton of angst
remember we're in chicago two years ago
yeah for the opener all the angst all
the dismay all the concern about
mitchell trubisky i mean so now they're
just carrying that around about justin
fields what do we have there's only one
way to find out let's go see what he has
let's open that envelope what do you
mean do not open until 2022 i want to
open it now yeah i want to see what this
guy is it's going to be hard for them to
push that's that's that's how i feel
exactly right it's going to be hard to
hold it off to go to 2022. and you know
i think realistically too when you look
at it we've talked about the nagi you
know and ryan pace how much longer do
they have how successful they may have
like yeah it seems like they at least
have two years with making that draft
pick and doing that so you know and i
look at the bears and go
you're not winning the super bowl this
year i don't mean to be disrespectful i
think they can be highly competitive in
a pain in the butt but i don't look at
them as a super bowl contender i don't
and you know they they have andy dalton
at quarterback say what you want to say
but that's the perception there so you
know why wouldn't you
you know okay yeah we're two and two or
we're three and two
and dalton's been good but not great why
wouldn't you want to get a guy out there
who we know is raw in some areas and
needs some work and they know that too
to where let's get it going let's get
some of these issues fixed let's get
them better now for 2022. uh that that's
where i think between all the things you
said there and all that that's where i
just think it's a lot different
situation that chiefs one and there's a
lot more pressure here and i just think
we're going to see justin fields early
on in the year for sure in some capacity
the situation also presents a challenge
for the coaching staff when it comes to
divvying up the reps of the matter yeah
to get andy dalton ready to get justin
fields ready you still got a super bowl
mvp lurking at the bottom of the depth
charting nick foles here's head coach
matt nagy talking about the plan when it
comes to figuring out who's going to get
those chances in practice to develop
i've talked to to all three of them and
as we go into
these practices as we go into training
camps knowing how valuable it is for for
justin to get his reps you know and and
andy obviously
uh to to get his reps too nick and i
have talked and he understands that
going into this that justin's going to
get the two reps and then nick's going
to get the three reps and uh nick is a
true pro and understands it uh is still
very competitive and that's why i say
like in all these meetings it's uh it's
just really special to see how they're
trying to help justin out and then and
and teach him how to play quarterback
and how to how to um watch film and
study this offense but also justin
helping them too with what he sees so
it's been really good
yeah hey look
it's i i don't envy the situation that
matt and aggie's in and i don't know how
much of this they sat down and
envisioned ahead of time but they had
months to plan they knew where they were
and i think you know part of the cover
to move up and get at justin fields was
go out and sign an andy dalton we said
that when the bear signed dalton and
washington signed ryan fitzpatrick that
took the
huge sign off the front lawn that said
get ready for us to draft a quarterback
in round one washington didn't
but there was talk that yeah there was
right up into the top ten to get trey
lance right and the bears did and uh now
you gotta go forward with it and you
know the the good news is
you got a guy who could develop into
your franchise quarterback the not so
good news is you got to get there first
yeah how they do it and that's why i
think
when when you're confronted with a
problem like this that can be an
unenviable one if you can resort to your
own experiences for a situation that
worked
that becomes the path because if it
blows up
if it blows up and matt and aggie's
facing the tough questions say hey i we
did it in kansas city with patrick
mahomes and it worked that was my
experience and i i i was not going to do
anything different than what was proven
to have worked with the chief so i don't
know over under
again mike glennon got four games before
they went with trubisky
i i don't know what's what's the over
under on starts with justin fields in
your mind i i mean i i think it's right
around that well i think it's right
around that area i think it's week three
or four i i you know i i've talked about
this on my podcast a little bit you know
i know i've said it to you and all those
type of things too it's just
i just have a hard time envisioning them
not letting him get in here or there
and
i i think he has a chance to be
like start 10 games maybe more i really
do i think eventually that's what's
gonna happen you know and
the fact that he's already number two
they're talking about getting them up to
speed and doing those things yeah nick
foles doesn't need reps if you have a 12
play seven on seven period i would bet
you justin fields and andy dalton are
gonna get about equal reps right now
let's say it's 12 plays i bet you andy
dawg gets the first five justin fields
gets the next five and nick foles gets
the last two plays there or it's like
five four and three something like that
but that's gotta be the number one goal
i mean they went all in on justin fields
they went all in that was a huge move
it's it's it's either going to make them
or break them pace or matinee so that's
where i just keep coming back to like
i i i i know what you're saying with the
formula and all of those type of things
but i don't think the bears fans are
expecting super bowl this year and i
would do something to me where i would
favor and let's get them excited for the
future let's get this guy ready and
let's not have to worry about having the
training wheels on them in 2022
uh to where now we feel like our team is
set up to do something special and now
our quarterback's not ready i think
that's really what the thought has to be
all year long for the chicago bears
can we pop the schedule back up because
i i think we need to understand how this
season could unfold getting to
understand how much time andy dalton
gets they're going to the rams right out
of the gate with aaron donald and jalen
ramsey and hey i don't know unless andy
dalton throws five interceptions i think
he gets a chance to host the team that
drafted him ten years ago week two home
opener cincinnati bengals and if you can
check that box with a win
then you get a chance to go back to
cleveland yeah a place where he's used
to playing during his time with
cincinnati and even if they lose that
game if he's respectable in that game
you got two winnable games sure all due
respect to the lions and the raiders you
got two winnable games that are on the
horizon after that before the season
really starts with packers bucks 49ers
steelers hello yeah so i i think he can
earn yeah based upon what he does the
first five games right
or doesn't do yeah and then maybe we see
fields but he could based on the first
five games earned the ability to embark
on this stretch
where it's either going to be flip to
justin fields at the bye week after the
steelers game or stick with dalton but
packers bucks 49er steelers if dalton
can earn the right to be the quarterback
going into that quartet of games
i think that goes a long way toward
determining whether it's fields or
dalton out or not right the way the
schedule sets up he's got a chance for
the first five yeah a smaller chance for
the next four
and then probably we go fields after the
bye week based upon that that murderer's
road to finish the first half of the
schedule could could be i could
certainly see that being a scenario and
there's no doubt about it what if they
get through those first five weeks like
you're talking about and they got a
favorable record would they think about
maybe doing like the miami dolphins
thing like last year where they just go
wait
i mean we got to get this guy in here i
mean
to to maybe
you know just get them playing not not
let andy dalton just thrive all year
long and then we'd be stuck in a that's
not going to happen that's a stupid
scenario so i'm going to dive down that
but here's another one but you know what
here here's another one though let me
let me tell you that let's let's test
this one out yeah i know we got to go to
break but i want to say one more thing
too yeah we're spitballing here yeah
what what if they flip to fields
what if what if we find out next year at
this time from justin feels he didn't
know the offense very well like tua said
last week and and we we see the relief
pitcher concept yeah that's what i mean
we see justin start and if and and uh
you know if it goes haywire in a given
game in comes andy dalton to mop it up
maybe we could see that i that's where i
was i was kind of going with that i i
was i guess i was
a little a different situation but not
totally i guess not really and
that's where i was kind of going with it
i do think miami kind of like broke the
ice with that like hey this is okay
it's not like taboo or forbidden to do
this
so maybe that's a possibility here's the
last thing before we go to break i just
want to ask you you talked about the
what if scenarios if it's positive for
the first five weeks what if they lose
to the rams and lose to the bengals
what if that then do you start to go
let's just get them going and let's get
the justin fields train rolling
i think in his return to ohio justin
fields will be
the starter yeah and all those folks
from columbus can buy their tickets for
the bears at brown's game and they can
wear their number one justin fields
jersey at their own peril at first
energy stage cleveland so yeah i think
that that if they start off owen two and
they lose to the bengals especially
given where the bengals are right now
joe burrow i think i think justin fields
has a very good chance to be the starter
come week three
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports